[Screams]
[Roar]
I promise to love
every part of you forever.
My girlfriend is...uh,
six months pregnant.
Oh, congratulations.
Do you know what you’re having?
[Growl]
[Screams]
My stepmom's a werewolf.
My name's
Detective Kate Cross.
We've had a new
piece of information
for a homicide investigation.
Did you see these gentlemen?
Why are you asking?
Surprise!
Daddy alert!
Who’s the hot guy?
Hello.
You're not from here?
Anton used to teach me in college.
Hmm.
Did he help in any other way?
What do you mean?
I mean, like, did
he help you with his penis?
Oh, my God, Gary!
Why are you here?
I'm here for you.
You need to
stay away from me...
because I'm going
to protect my pack.
You're bleeding.
Maybe the
universe is trying to tell us
that this
is too dangerous.
I love you
and that is the
only thing that matters.
The universe can go
and eat a bag of dicks.
That's the most romantic thing
anyone's ever said to me.